bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe
hebdo nous sommes ensemble à bruxelles
pour 30 minutes d'actualité européenne
dans cette émission nous nous pencherons
sur la réforme du marché du travail à
l'heure où en france la loi elle comme
riz commence à être examiné à
l'assemblée nationale nous nous sommes
rendus au pays bas pays où en moyenne on
travaille 30 heures par semaine
un choix pour beaucoup qui offre plus de
flexibilité pour les entreprises est une
contrainte pour certains qui doivent
cumuler les emplois pour s'en sortir
mais avant de nous rendre en hollande
direction la chine en décembre prochain
l'europe doit décider si oui ou non elle
donne le statut d'économie de marché à
l' empire du milieu
une décision dont les conséquences
pourraient être catastrophiques sur le
marché de l'emploi en europe alors le
statut d'économie de marché kézaco on en
parle tout de suite
l'enjeu est énorme et le calendrier
contraint alors en europe les secteurs
touchés se mobilisent objectif faire
pression sur les gouvernements et la
commission européenne
fait inédit c'est le secteur de la
métallurgie en allemagne qui a ouvert le
bal des manifestations
manifestons contre le prix de l'acier
qui vient de chine
nous voulons que les tarifs soient plus
élevés pour l'acier qui arrive de là bas
pour que l'industrie de l'acier en
allemagne et en union européenne se
porte mieux
la chine est de loin le plus gros
producteur d'acier au monde en 25 ans le
pays a multiplié par douze sa production
pour ses infrastructures ses logements
maintenant que son économie ralentit
elle inonde le marché européen d'acier à
bas prix et toof l'industrie européenne
déjà mal en point
on n'est juste pas compétitifs les
chinois nous ont doublé sur une nuit
s'ils ont monopolisé le marché est bon
on ne peut pas fonctionner aussi papou
que la chine est elle une économie de
marché voilà la question à laquelle la
commission européenne doit répondre
avant décembre prochain une décision
lourde de sens et qui risque d'avoir des
conséquences désastreuses sur de
nombreux secteurs d'activité en europe
à la clé des centaines de milliers
d'emplois détruits en france des
millions sur le territoire européen
mais les 28 cents divisé si nous ne
voulons pas considérer que nous agissons
à 28 et que nous regardons chacun nos
agendas particulier nous commettons une
erreur à court terme c'est de la naïveté
un peu cynique et une vraie faute
politique et morale à long terme
face à cette levée de boucliers la chine
dispose de plusieurs armes et le fait
savoir elle investit énormément en
europe et financent en partie le plan
juncker ce plan d'investissement de 315
milliards d'euros destiné à relancer la
croissance européenne
des arguments de poids alors la chine
est-elle une économie de marché voilà la
difficile la difficile question à
laquelle la commission européenne doit
répondre d'ici quelques mois et pour
poser cette question je reçois franck
proust
bonjour vous êtes député européen membre
du groupe parti populaire européen les
républicains en france dont vous êtes le
secrétaire national au commerce
extérieur bienvenue à vous en face de
vous edouard martin bonjour bonjour
bienvenue vous êtes vous membre ici du
groupe socialiste et démocrate et vous
êtes ancien syndicaliste au sein de la
cfdt bienvenue à vous enfin claude rolin
bonjour vous êtes également député
européen vous est également membre du
groupe parti populaire européen et vous
êtes belge et vous êtes également ancien
110 syndicaliste vous êtes l'ancien
secrétaire général de la confédération
des syndicats chrétiens ici en belgique
bienvenu à vous messieurs
diriez vous que c'est un véritable
danger si la chine obtient ce statut
d'économie de marché et finalement
qu'est-ce que c'est ce statut d'économie
de marché france rustre en fait la
reconnaissance d'un statut d'économie de
marché
ça permet de teint prix d'un bien situé
d'un prix normal de le traduire en prix
domestiques
est ce que oui ou non les prix
domestiques pratiqué en chine sont des
prix nombre la réponse est bien
évidemment non je crois qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde est unanime là dessus mais
en fait la situation aujourd'hui reflète
un flou juridique
on voudrait nous faire croire que la
clause de révision puisque je rappelle
que quand la chine atteint d adhérer à
l'om c'est en 2001 il y avait une clause
de révision qui faisait qu'en 2016 c'est
à dire le 11 décembre là pour une fois
il ya un calendrier très précis on
devait revoir la méthodologie concernant
le calcul d'un prix de revient et
certains juristes de la commission
voudrait nous faire croire que la
redéfinition de ce mode de calcul c'est
quelque chose de strictement technique
finale tu as fait ton gendre mais très
important puisque c'est ce qui va
définir
ce qu'on appelle le prix normal qui est
alors pour être des refrains de pouce
parce que nous qui ne sommes pas
économiste le prix normal est de prix
domestiques c'est quoi ça veut dire que
pour avoir le prix normal que ça vaut
sur le marché par exemple ont enlevé par
exemple les aides publiques il faudra
tout à fait vous avez une vigie
n'importe quoi une bicyclette qui sort
de chine à 20 euros vous l'exporter
alors que en fait la plupart des pays
qui sont dans cet ensemble de statut
d'économie de marché ont un prix normal
qui est de 40 euros
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui l'art
est énorme voilà disparités énormes et
donc à une taxe anti dumping qui est
appliqué pour essayer de ramener le prix
normal aux prix domestiques alors
edouard martin quel est le problème
finalement si ce statut est accordé à la
chine
moi je vais rebondir sur ce qui a été
dit effectivement la commission et les
juristes veulent nous embarquer donné
dans un discours extrêmement technique
et juridique c'est extrêmement compliqué
hier j'ai envie de dire moi je suis un
élu nous sommes des élus ici autant nous
avons été élus par les citoyens
européens la seule question qui vaille à
mon sens c est ce que reconnaître ce
statut et la chine est ce que c'est bon
pour les citoyens européens pour
l'europe
oui et non la réponse c'est non parce
que on a vu dans le reportage
un exemple le secteur de l'acier qui
subit actuellement une concurrence comme
jamais la nation c'est à dire que les
chiots un même sillon alors même que la
chine n'a pas le statut d'économie de
marché il ya déjà une concurrence énorme
salaces et dont on nous parle souvent du
miracle chinois mais quand même quoi il
arrive à nous produire une tonne d'acier
quasiment au même prix que la matière
première que le minerai qui en achètent
pour pour faire l'acier est
effectivement rester là où nous aurons
nous je pense une grosse difficultés sur
les deux plaintes anti dumping c'est
pour que là pour que la l'om s'y
reconnaissent qu'ils aiment ping il faut
qu'on prouve que le prix effectivement
pratiqué suroît le marché local est
supérieur aux prix pratiqués à
l'exportation hors sur l'a6
effectivement ce même prix mais derrière
ça il se cache une la magie chinoise
c'est que c'est à coup de subventions
qu'ils arrivent à maintenir des prix
extrêmement bas donc il faudra aussi se
battre contre les subventions publiques
dont bénéficient beaucoup de secteurs de
l'économie chinoise on parle de l'acier
la nuit
homme le papier la chimie donc ça peut
avoir un impact négatif sur plusieurs
millions d'emplois sur le secteur dans
le territoire européen et donc c'est
absolument pas pensable qu'on puisse
reconnaître ce statut à la chimie alors
claude rolin on voit bien qu'il ya des
risques pour l'emploi notamment l'acier
la céramique fin vous le disiez comment
se fait-il que du coup au vu de son par
la fourchette basse et quelques
centaines de milliers d'emplois
fourchette aux plusieurs millions
d'emplois détruits en europe
comment se fait-il que du coup on en
soit encore aujourd'hui à se poser la
question de donner ce statut à la chine
parce que le premier il se fait au
moment où on a intégré
l'om c'est la chine plutôt dans l'om
c'est en ayant décidé d'une procédure
procédure qui arrive à un traitement
particulier une méthodologie
particulière sur les règles anti-dumping
ça arrive en expiration fin 2016 rudy se
pose la question est ce qu'on va ou non
me octroyé ce statut d'économie de
marché
or il est clair edouard l'a dit tout à
l'heure si nous octroyons ce statut ça
veut dire une catastrophe en termes
d'emploi si je prends simplement la
chirurgie les outils en termes d'acier
eh bien il faut savoir que nous n'aurons
plus aucune entreprise qui sera en
capacité de produire dans les coûts qui
seront imposées par la chine aujourd'hui
produit beaucoup plus que ce que la
planète a besoin à des prix qui sont les
nouveaux art en ciel sans tenir compte
d'un salaire minimum sans tenir compte
de conditions de travail sans tenir
compte de conditions environnementales
en injectant de l'argent public dans
cette production en europe
moi je me souviens comme syndicaliste au
début de ma carrière j'ai vécu une des
premières restructuration d'un outil
serrure gic en belgique qui était
accusant sud de la belgique
on a fermé cet outil là puis on a fermé
longwy en france et d'autres outils
pourquoi notamment parce que nous
devions réguler notre production d'acier
pour ne pas avoir une surproduction nous
avons fait tous ses efforts avec des
drames sociaux avec des drames humains
avec des drames économiques et demain on
se retrouvait dans une situation où un
acteur nous inondent complètement et
détruit nos outils surfer pourquoi la
chine produit autant dans ce cas là
franck proust quel est le problème
avec la chine la chine ne respecte pas
grand chose aussi bien sur les volumes
que sur les tarifs mais aujourd'hui à
mon sens ce qui est important c'est que
on n'est plus à l'époque de savoir si on
doit lui octroyer oui ou non ce statut
d'économie de marché
je crois ce qui est important c'est de
savoir comment on va dire non parce que
le grand débat qui se pose derrière
c'est pour ça qu'ils aient des gens qui
hésitent c'est que il ya un problème
diplomatique
tout le monde a peur des mesures de
rétorsion parce que tout compte fait
alors les mesures de rétorsion pour être
clair c'est une fermeture du marché
chinois aux entreprises européennes tout
à fait donc il va falloir avoir une
solution peut-être diplomatique une
grande solidarité entre pays européens
peut-être également pour une fois avec
les états unis et japon puisque le japon
les états unis et l'europe sont les
trois partenaires principaux de la chine
mais il va falloir aussi une grande
sincérité de la part de nos dirigeants
politiques edouard martin le sait la
règle du droit moindres quand j'entends
monsieur cameron en angleterre dire
qu'il veut protéger son industrie mais
nous empêche de supprimer le droit -
vous savez une fois moins de salariés
doit maintenant être car c'est cher très
clair c'est à dire que quand les
américains mais deux mois à réagir quand
ils constatent une infraction émettre
200 % de taxes antidumping nous en au
repos mais neuf mois et on met une taxe
qui est à proportionnelle aux dommages
subis et non pas une taxe qui est une
valeur punitive et parce qu'on avait 28
ans
on met 15 % quoi pourquoi on met autant
de temps parce qu'on a une autre
philosophie en europe
est ce que c'est de la naïveté ce que
c'est de la prétention c'est à dire
qu'on veut toujours privilégier les
bonnes relations commerciales
sauf que moi je suis pas protectionniste
je suis pour la mondialisation
à condition toutefois que tout le monde
ait les mêmes règles avec les mêmes
edouard martin vous vous avez vous êtes
monté au créneau pour faire en sorte que
ce débat soit connue vous avez lancé
aussi un site internet pour essayer de
me semble quelques-uns 72 voilà
eurodéputés transnationales trans
partisan parce qu'effectivement c'est un
débat qui doit concerner et on voit bien
que l'ensemble des 28 pays avec 107
millions de citoyens européens qui
aujourd'hui ne le perçois peut-être pas
mais c'est un véritable risque un
véritable danger
sur le secteur de l'acier par exemple où
effectivement l'hypocrisie de monsieur
cameron
enfin révélé au grand jour et vous avez
vu ce qu avait ce qu'avait annoncé tata
steel 2 en grande bretagne il se désole
tata steel ne se désengage pas de
l'acier en europe est producteur d'acier
l'acier tata s'ils se désengagent de
l'angleterre uniquement de la grande
bretagne parce que le patron de tata
steel a dit publiquement
voilà un pays sur lequel je suis
implanté et les dirigeants ne sont pas
capables ne veulent pas défendre un
secteur industriel qui contribuent à la
belle économie
pour être clair la décision doit être
prise pour le 11 décembre prochain
comment est ce que le parlement européen
et a fortiori les syndicats concernés
vont pouvoir faire pression sur la
commission sur le conseil pour que cette
décision soit finalement négatif vous
parliez tout à l'heure franck proust de
la nécessité en fait d'être diplomate
avec la chine parce que effectivement
dans l'autre sens c'est quand même
beaucoup d'investissements chinois en
europe les mesures de rétorsion et ce
fameux plan et en choeur qui en partie
financé par des fonds chinois
comment on fait je crois que bon il ya
déjà un débat la semaine prochaine à
strasbourg qui engendrera vraisemblement
mes résolutions au mois de juin il va y
avoir des études que la commission même
juge toujours très prudent et table en u
à la fois sion si on octroyer le statut
et si on le ne le croyais pas mais je
crois que sincèrement encore une fois
c'est plus sur la méthodologie il va
falloir qu'on gagne du temps et qu'on
travaille avec la commission sur la
révision de ce qu'on appelle les idées
c'est nos instruments de défense pour
enfin avoir des instruments de défense
qui correspondent au mode au monde
aujourd'hui être efficace est performant
et surtout quand on constate une
infraction pouvoir avoir de la
réactivité comme dans le monde de
l'entreprise et ne pas attendre neuf
mois mais deux mois quand on regarde
l'histoire des panneaux photovoltaïques
on voit là a été fixée les panneaux on a
commencé à réagir quand tout le monde
était mort et une fois qu'on ait réagi
le premier ministre chinois est venu en
allemagne voir madame merkel a fait
pression par rapport au secteur
automobile comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure
conclusion c'est les vins français et
les spiritueux qui ont les mesures de
rétention dont je parlais à la fois
d'une grande solidarité européenne
une solidarité internationale peut-être
voire même la création d'un fonds
spécifique pour surmonter les
difficultés à court terme d'éventuels de
mesures de rétorsion et préparer
l'avenir mais surtout se doter d'outils
qui soient des outils efficaces
edouard martin vous êtes confiant sur la
possibilité de non pas du tout je n'ai
aucune confiance aux relations
commerciales économiques avec la chine
mais ça a été dit quand la chine n'y
trouve pas son compte et le menace elle
prend des mesures de rétorsion alors
qu'il entre à le frapper à la porte de
l'om c'est aujourd'hui le seul pays qui
officiellement s'est déclaré contre la
reconnaissance du statut d'école marche
à la chine c'est l'italie les autres
n'osent pas parce qu'effectivement on
craint tous des mesures de rétention et
derrière ça la chine a une véritable
politique industrielle et ceux qui en
europe il y en a nous avons des
commissaires qui ne défendent pas le
secteur industriel qui disent qu'ils
veulent effectivement minimiser l'impact
sur les emplois du ce qu'elle et qui
disons au poids compensés par les
emplois de service mais si vous regardez
bien les chiffres d'investissement en
chine
ils vont investir des dizaines et
dizaines de milliards dans les services
ils vont s'améliorer et d'une de 2 sur
le secteur de l'acier aujourd'hui dans
la production mondiale
il n'y a pas un industriel qui gagnent
de l'argent pour dix ans de l'acier y
compris les chinois et chinois perd 2,55
dollars par tonne d'acier produites
mais tout ça c'est compensé par des
subventions publiques et l'idée c'est
quoi c'est effectivement d'être les
maîtres du marché mondial et le jour où
nous aurons disparu et ceux qui disent
c'est bon pour notre économie
parce que ça va nous permettre pendant
un temps d'acier d'acheter l'acier moins
cher mais plus tard lorsqu'on ne
produira plus d'acier parce que c'est
indépendant de l'acier chinois et ils
pourront nous imposer les prix qu'ils
veulent donc c'est vraiment une vue à
très court termiste que d'accepter ce
statut à la chine
c'est déjà la cas aujourd'hui je me
souviens il ya deux ans trois ans même
j'étais rapporteur au comité économique
et social européen justement sur le
plantier l'analyse que nous faisions
employeurs et responsables syndicaux
s'étaient quand quatre reprise
économique
aujourd'hui en europe nous n'avions plus
les outils pour produire simplement la
cible dont nous avons déjà le joint nous
sommes des gens dans cette année nation
donc c'est un massacre économique il
faut l'arrêter
des outils lors la confiance mais le
politique doit jouer son rôle
la commission doit être consciente des
problèmes et de l'avenir de l'économie
européenne mais je crois et nous croyons
à quelques en plus qu'un qu'il faut
aussi une mobilisation citoyenne
c'est à dire que les citoyens que des
européens rennes conscience en fait des
récipients ou non des enjeux et le rôle
de citoyen peut être important ouais
faut jamais oublier on l'a vu sur le
taffetas notamment pas le trait des
transactions et devant les citoyens à
l'agenda
excusez moi quand même qu'un seul à
13,52 procédures antidumping à l'égard
de la chine ont donc ce qui montre qu'il
ya un véritable problème
à la relance il ya un autre dossier sur
lesquels les citoyens se sont mobilisés
ces derniers jours c'est la loi travail
en france la loi travail qui arrive à
l'assemblée à partir de cette semaine
qui est en examen alors dans ce texte il
est question donc de réformer le marché
du travail en france allant du coup nous
avons voulu savoir comment nos voisins
européens s'étaient débrouillés de leur
côté pour créer cette fameuse
flexisécurité que chapin chacun au
pardon appelle de ses voeux
en hollande par exemple on travaille en
moyenne 30 heures par semaine louis
sybille a été voir comment cela se passe
café en terrasse ou bronzette au parc
le matin certains hollandais ne se
pressent pas pour aller au travail
et pour cause ici la moyenne ces 30
heures par semaine un record européen
la moitié des personnes pratiquent le
temps partiel c'est trois fois plus
qu'en france
exemple dans cette entreprise de
pneumatiques qui emploie 700 salariés
normalement il ya six personnes qui
travaillent ici et comme vous le voyez
il ya de la place disponible à cause du
temps partiel souvent pris l'eau
mercredi et le vendredi
bonjour ici chacun gère son emploi du
temps
les ressources humaines sont habitués un
maître mot la flexibilité ça va bien
quelques jours tu as choisi toi j'ai
choisi le mercredi pour mon jour de
repos j'ai vu ça avec mon équipe on
essaie de calais toutes les réunions de
l'entreprise le lundi et si quelqu'un ne
peut pas si on lui demande de passer un
coup de fil ou de faire une
visioconférence depuis une loi de l'an
un salarié peut demander à être
embauchés au temps partiel il le patron
ne peut pratiquement pas refuser le
temps de travail peut même être
annualisé et si on a une vingtaine de
personnes se fait partie justement des
activités saisonnières
c'est un département en fait qui qui
compte à peu près cinq personnes hors
saison et qui monte jusqu'à une
vingtaine de personnes en pleine saison
c'est à dire maintenant chacun y trouve
son compte
même le dirigeant car son entreprise
reste compétitive si on était bloqué par
des temps de travail à temps complet
s'il n'avait pas cette flexibilité je
pense qu'on pourrait pas on pourrait pas
s'adapter notamment aux fortes 16 ans la
hollande est l'un des pays les plus
productifs d'europe
même en travaillant un peu les à leers
ou très élevé environ 3500 euros par
mois mais non pour avoir un bon niveau
de vie aux pays-bas
vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir
l'équivalent de temps plein c'est un
luxe que l'on peut avoir ici et je pense
que le vecteur le plus important de la
compétitivité
c'est le haut niveau de formation et
d'éducation de la masse salariale
nous retrouvons christian papa depuis
sept mois
il a décidé de prendre une journée par
semaine pour s'occuper de son ouvre un
grand salut ça va monter
c'est très important pour moi de le voir
grandir
ça n'a pas de prix christian alterne la
garde avec sa femme et ça évite de payer
une crèche qui coûte très cher aux pays
bas son temps partiel représentent un
manque à gagner de plusieurs centaines
d'euros car ma femme compense avec son
emploi en fait elle travaille plus
depuis que je suis en temps partiel qui
gagnent moins
mais si on fait le total avec son
salaire ça équilibre au pressing très
haut en réalité le temps partiel
concerne surtout les femmes elles sont
80 % à le pratiquer contre 30% pour les
hommes une attitude qui perdure certaine
tradition les pays bas n'ont pas
participé à la première guerre mondiale
et donc les femmes en fait n'ont pas
commencé à travailler comme dans les
autres pays où les hommes est envoyé au
front donc traditionnellement les femmes
sont pas très présents sur marché de
travail
par ailleurs c'est un pays qui a
toujours eu des des gouvernements
démocrates chrétiens ou la place de la
femme est à la maison en fait travailler
pour une femme et découragés du fait des
taxes avons payé ici le taux de chômage
est l'un des plus faibles d'europe 7%
mais beaucoup d'emplois sont précaires
avec un temps partiel imposé ces jeunes
militants syndiqués manifeste d'un fast
food
outre des petits boulots mal payés
aux pays bas un jeune peut commencer à
travailler à l'âge de 13 ans et n'être
payé que t'être euros de l'heure
certains employeurs préfèrent donc
multiplier de jeunes recrues à temps
partiel si quelqu'un est malade c'est
plus facile de le remplacer pour une
entreprise ça lui revient moins cher
mais les employés eux ne travaillent pas
assez et ne gagne pas assez d'argent
pour joindre les doubistes tariche à
mathurin est étudiante en anglais elle a
enchaîné trois temps partiel depuis
qu'elle a 15 ans
je lui ai dit à mon boss qu'avec ce
salaire je peux me payer que la moitié
de mon beau regard aujourd'hui elle
travaille 20 heures par semaine et pour
elle c'est synonyme de précarité
je suis indépendante donc j'habite dans
un studio
ça fait 500 euros par mois ça représente
100 heures de travail pour moi c'est
donc très dur d'entreprendre des études
à côté dans ses concessions
aujourd'hui 60 % des jeunes sont
employés à temps partiel avec des
conséquences importantes sur le moral
dont les catégories les plus
défavorisées
près d'un sur dix a connu un temps à
autre
alors cette flexisécurité est elle un
nouveau contrat social et peut-elle
nuire ou non à la compétitivité franck
proust l'exemple la hollandais pourrait
potentiellement être importée en france
ou pas je le dire qu'il m'a pas
véritablement séduit parce que avoir un
temps partiel c'est un choix de vie
qualité de vie mais est ce que pour
autant il ya un véritable pouvoir
d'achat derrière et la hollande la avec
un salaire moyen de 3500 euros c'est
plutôt intéressant mais vous parle aussi
de de gens qui touche 4 euros de l'heure
on voit des jeunes qui démarrent à 13
ans
moi je suis pour l'apprentissage dès 14
ans c'est parce que derrière c'est pour
apprendre un métier devenir opérationnel
à 18 démarré à 13 ans avec 4 euros de
l'heure je pense pas que ça soit une
philosophie de vie qui puisse satisfaire
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens mais par
contre ce que je voudrais dire et ce qui
me paraît intéressant c'est la notion
d'annualisation du temps de travail
je pense à des secteurs comme le
tourisme ou autre ou effectivement on
doit être très flexibles et aujourd'hui
vouloir légiférer pour tous les secteurs
avoir une durée hebdomadaire de travail
qu'ils soient figées
ça devient compliqué et je crois qu'il
est nécessaire d'évoluer en fonction là
encore de la vie des entreprises
pourrait être de plus en plus compétitif
vous êtes d'accord edouard martin
annualisé le train de travail pourquoi
pas finalement mais ça existe déjà
la loi aubry moi je viens d'un secteur
des entreprises montrent on travaillait
et annualisées à par accord de branche
ce qui en l'occurrence est effectivement
pointé du doigt et un reproche auquel
j'adhère sur la loi elle comme riz
justement parce que la victime ont le
temps partiel s'il est choisi pourquoi
pas mais là c'est du temps partiel
imposé et une partie effectivement les
plus jeunes les femmes etc
si c'est si c'est un choix pourquoi pas
mais sur la nouvelle connerie ce qui va
et ce qui va gêner est ce qui gêne et
vraiment c'est les causes qui enclenche
ronde des licenciements collectifs
le simple fait d'avoir pendant x
trimestre une baisse du chiffre
d'affaires pourra permettre demain
l'employeur de licenciés collectivement
on vient de parler de la chine je prends
un lecteur le secteur de l'acier en
emploi les travailleurs européens et
français sont ils responsables du baisse
du chiffre d'affaires des usines d'acier
en rien et pourtant
lors du vote de cette loi si elle est
votée en l'état est bien une multitude
d'entreprises pourront licencié parce
que leur chiffre d'affaires aura baissé
mais baisse de chiffre d'affaires ne
veut pas dire mécaniquement est
automatiquement ses pertes d'argent et
mai mais là on est face à un des sujets
que nous nous maîtrisons pas
et c'est vraiment l'orientation
européenne parce que lorsqu'on regarde
le projet de loi elle comrie il
ressemble étrangement au projet à la loi
espagnole faits à l'époque par monsieur
lacroix et on voit ce que ça a donné par
circulaire 100% de cdd de moins d'un
mois et la précarité a explosé mais
alors claude rolin ya aussi je crois en
belgique en ce moment une réflexion
autour d'une réforme du marché du
travail
l'idée c'est quoi c'est d'aller vers
l'exemple hollandais en tout cas ce qui
en belgique ça c'est n'ont d'ailleurs
pas ce qu'est la belgique est un pays de
concertation sociale
il ya aujourd'hui une volonté d'un
gouvernement d'imposer un peu quelque
chose comme en france alors que nous
avons une flexibilité importantes avec
des systèmes d'annualisation avec y
compris nous avons inventé au travers de
la concertation sociale
un système spécifique pour les
travailleurs du secteur automobile où on
travaille on conduit le temps de travail
en fonction de la durée de vie de la
production d'un véhicule mais pour moi
et je suis d'accord je trouve que le
terme de flexisécurité me convient mais
il me convient à une condition d'avoir
une flexibilité et d'avoir une sécurité
les entreprises ont besoin de
flexibilité les travailleurs ont besoin
de flexibilité aussi à condition qu'ils
correspondent à leurs besoins des uns et
des autres nous avons les uns les autres
les entreprises et les travailleurs
besoin de sécurité
nous avons aussi besoin de prévisibilité
mais comment on installe c'est bien si
c'est qu'il ya une seule mais notre
possible c'est la concertation sociale
dès le départ et ce sont les acteurs de
terrain les chefs d'entreprise les
représentants des travailleurs qui sont
les mieux placés pour donner les
solutions et l'arrêt doit maintenant les
additions d'accord ce que je vois
derrière on en parle et à l'heure du
plan juncker et le plan juncker il ya un
fonds public à peu près de 26 milliards
qui aidé
dié a rassuré les investisseurs' et leur
dire venez investir chez nous rassurez
vous vous ne prendrez part de risque que
ce nouvel essai quelques milliards vont
permettre de faire un effet levier pour
les opérateurs privés via l'art est ce
que aujourd'hui justement le premier là
c'est que l'investisseur le financier ne
veut plus prendre de risques c'est
risque zéro donc il faut bien que
quelqu'un prenne ce risque là c'est le
salarié qui aujourd'hui on doit y
apporter tout le risque effectivement
flexisécurité je veux dire chiche
pourquoi pas et dans ce cas là il faut
il faut qu'on construise un modèle
social qu'ils soient rattachés aux
salariés n'ont pu opposer de travail non
plus à l'entreprise
et ça il faut qu'il y ait des
financements publics derrière
aujourd'hui les entreprises ne veulent
ni financer parce qu'elles disent quand
pète trop de charges et elles veulent
pas prendre de risques à un moment donné
ça m'étonne pas que les salariés se
révoltent ajuste je suis en partie
d'accord sauf que aujourd'hui aussi on a
en france un tissu de petites
entreprises et aujourd'hui la
problématique du chef d'entreprise k23
salariés équipe demain si on lui
accorder un petit peu plus de souplesse
pourrait embaucher la création d'emplois
les plus dans les petits réduite ces
entreprises que dans les multinationales
non j'ai en ce cas là pourquoi ne pas
créer deux systèmes en fait de loi pour
les grosses entreprises les dames il
faut pas tout réglementer les lois
simplement il faut rassurer les chefs
d'entreprises parce que le grand
problème qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui il
se dit aujourd'hui j'ai du travail
demain j'en ai plus qu est ce qui se
passe et donc on a une paralysie du
monde économique et surtout dans la
décision de pouvoir embaucher
c'est ça qui est dramatique mais en
france on veut tout légiférer sur tous
les secteurs
laissons faire les accords de branche et
laissons faire la concertation je suis
d'accord avec mon collègue entre les
salariés les chefs d'entreprise ça me
paraît la solution ne se sera
effectivement edouard martin n'est
toujours pas d'accord mais je pense que
là dessus vous avez été d'accord en fait
sur ce statut d'économie de marché mais
sur la réforme du travail
malheureusement ce ne sera pas pour
cette fois
merci messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci à vous de nous
avoir expliqué ces questions assez
difficile bien entendu on en reparlera
d'ici là la semaine prochaine vous
retrouverez ahmed tazir depuis
strasbourg et bonne suite de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires ciao